قال بنيامين نتنياهو ان العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه في جنين ستستمر حتى تحقيق
الاهداف المرسومه لها مضيفا ان تلك
العمليه فرضت معادله ميدانيه جديده لا
تبقي ملاذا امنا لكل من يستهدف اسرائيل من
جهتها وعدت المقاومه الفلسطينيه بمواصله
تصديها للتصعيد الاسرائيلي معتبره عمليه
الدهس في تل ابيب مجرد بدايه لرد واسع
عليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف نفهم
رهان حكومه نتنياهو على التصعيد العسكري
ضد المقاومه برغم عدم تاخر ردها وفي جبهات
متعدده وما موقف المجتمع الدولي من خيار
التصعيد الاسرائيلي بالنظر مما يجلبه من
تصعيد المواجهه في كل مره
ما هي خيارات الفلسطينيين تجاه هذا
التصعيد وعمت سياسات واهداف حكومه نتنياهو
وهل ارتقت قرارات السلطه واستعدادات
الفصائل الفلسطينيه الى خطوره التحديات
التي طرحتها العمليه الاسرائيليه ما ملامح
الوضع الذي ستذهب نحوه الضفه الغربيه
وعامه المنطقه بعد انتهاء العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه وكيف سيتعامل الموقف
الاقليمي والدولي مع التعقيدات الجديده
التي خلقها التصعيد ومنها سقوط تفاهمات
العقبه
[موسيقى]
ما انطفات نار منطفات نار للتصعيد العسكري
بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين الا واوقد رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتانياهو
اخرى بنفس الذريعه الا وهي القضاء على ما
لا يقل عن وصفه بالعنف والارهاب الفلسطيني
هكذا يقول منتقدوا قائد فريق حكومي ينعت
حتى داخل اسرائيل نفسها بالاشد يمينيه
وتطرفا وهم يتابعون رد فعل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في تل ابيب وهو يشدد على ان رد
الفعل الفلسطيني سيبقى قائما في وجه اي
تصعيد اسرائيلي متحدثه باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قالت ان القضاء على ما وصفته
بالارهاب لا يتم في يوم واحد ولا بعمليه
عسكريه واحده الجيش الاسرائيلي اضاف انه
لا ينوي البقاء في جنين لكنه مستعد لحرب
طويله الامد في المقابل شددت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه على لسان حركتي حماس والجهاد
على ان المقاومه ستواصل التصدي للتصعيد
الاسرائيلي مهما كانت الظروف مشيره الى ان
عمليه تل ابيب لا تعدو ان تكون سوى رساله
وبدايه لرد واسع على اجنده نتنياهو
التصعيديه التي قالت ان مصيرها الحتمي
سيكون الفشل في نهايه المطاف
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من القدس ام
يخاي شتاين مراسل شؤون الدبلوماسيه في
هيئه البث الاسرائيليه سيد ماذا نفهم عما
تحقق من هذه العمليه بالنظر الى تصريحات
رئيس الحكومه نتانياهو وما يصدر عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي
اسرائيل كانت تنظر باتجاه امرين اولا
القضاء على
الارهابيين داخل جنين وتوقيف الارهابيين
وتدمير البنى التحتيه للارهاب في جنين
الانجاز الثاني والذي لا نعرفه اليوم بعد
سوف يتطلب الامر وقتا لكي نعرف ما اذا تم
تحقيقه هو منع من ان تكون جنين ملاذا امنا
للارهابيين لان اسرائيل كانت لا تدخل الى
جنين واذا ما دخلت في عمليه الى داخل مخيم
جنين هي بحاجه الى قوات مسلحه اكثر الى
حشد قوات مسلحه اكثر من اي مدينه اخرى
وبالتالي ارادت ان تشن هذه العمليه
اسرائيل كي لا تكون جنين ملادا امنا وهو
الهدف الثاني لهذه العمليه ويتعين علينا
ان نعرف النتيجه في الايام والاسابيع
المقبل طيب تح العمليه في جنين والرد ياتي
في تل ابيب ما الجدوى اذا
في الحقيقه الهجمات الارهابيه تحصل في كل
يوم في كل اسبوع وفي كل شهر حتى من دون
عمليات اسرائيليه ان القول ان الهجوم
الارهابي هو رد على العمليه في الجنين هذا
ما تقوله
منظمه الارهابيه ولكن في نهايه المطاف ما
حصل في تل ابيب هو هجوم يسمى بالذئب
المنفرد وهناك شخص يقوم بطعن اشخاص اخرين
وهذه اشكال من الهجمات التي نعرفها في
اسرائيل ان اسرائيل تقول ان العمليه
الارهابيه غير مرتبطه بعمليه جنين لانه
اولا الشخص هو من منطقه اخرى وهذا النوع
من الهجمات لسوء الحظ نشهده في كل يوم
واسبوع وشهد في
التبني التبني كان واضح انه رد على ما
يحصل في جنين وان هناك المزيد الذي سيعقد
ربما هذه العمليه ولكن سيد أمي ان كانت
العمليات تحصل كما قلت ووفق المنظور
الاسرائيلي انها تحصل في كل يوم وفي كل
اسبوع وانها ستبقى تحصل اذا ما الجدوى من
اي عمليه عسكريه ولماذا يعني استهداف جنين
يعني لا يوجد الان في اسرائيل من يعتقد او
يفكر بان مثل هكذا حلول يلجا اليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي لا جدوى منها
كلا لا اعتقد ان الناس ترى ان هذه
العمليات لا جدوى منها يجب ان نتذكر السبب
وراء هذه العمليات في المقام الاول وفقا
لاتفاقيه اوسلو منذ 30 عاما واكثر ان
المنظمه او المجموعه التي كان يفترض ان
تكافح هؤلاء الارهابيين ومنع الارهابيين
من التغلغل في المدن هو السلطه الفلسطينيه
ولكن في السنوات الاخيره السلطه
الفلسطينيه لا تقوم باي شيء
لمواجهتها هؤلاء وبالتالي يتعين على الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يقوم بهذه العمليات في داخل
المدن في كل ليله ما يحصل على سبيل المثال
اليوم الناطق باسم الرئاسه الفلسطينيه في
حديثا مع قناه الجزيره يقول ان العمليه في
جنين ترمي الى تصفيه القضيه الفلسطينيه لو
نظرنا الى تصريحات وردت على لسان شاول
مفاز في عام 2002 عندما كانت هناك عمليه
اسرائيليه تنفذ ضد جنين لوجدنا انها قريبه
جدا الى ما يقوله نتانياهو اليوم والجيش
الاسرائيلي والمسؤولين الاسرائيليين اليوم
وبالتالي انطلاقا من ذلك الا ترى اسرائيل
او المسؤولين الاسرائيليين ان هذه العمليه
تاتي بردات فعل عكسيه هي وان الحلول في
مكان اخر المشكله هي اساسا في الاحتلال
وفي الاستيطان وفي تمكين المستوطنين
مجددا ان الحل بالنسبه الى ما يحصل هذا
موضوع نقاشا كبير وهناك محاولات جرت بشكل
متكرر ولكن دعونا نتحدث عما يحصل في هذه
المدن ما يحصل في هذه المدن هو ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه تخسر سيطرتها على هذه المدن لو
تصرفت السلطه الفلسطينيه في مواجهه هذه
المنظمات الارهابيه في المدن ما كانت
لتخسر النفوذ والارهابيون ما كانوا ليشنوا
الهجمات الارهابيه التي تستهدف اسرائيل
نعم الناطقون رسميون يقولون ذلك ولكن انا
اعرف انه خلف الكواليس في رام الله هناك
اشخاص يراقبون
ويرون هذه العمليه تقضي على معارضه السلطه
الفلسطينيه ويبتسمون ازاء ما تقوم به
اسرائيل ولكن ايضا الا يوجد في اسرائيل من
يعتقد او يفهم ان خساره السلطه الفلسطينيه
ان كانت هناك من خساره هي بسبب عدم دعمها
لخيار المقاومه الذي يبدو انه خيارا ياخذ
شعبيه اكبر في الشارع الفلسطيني لا سيما
في الضفه بالنظر الى الممارسات ممارسات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
يمكننا بكل تاكيد ان نقول ان المجموعات
الارهابيه او شعبيه
العمليات الارهابيه تزداد الى اخره ولكن
في نهايه المطاف هل التود السلطه
الفلسطينيه ان تتحكم وتسيطر على المناطق
التي يتعين عليها ان تسيطر عليها اذا ما
كانت تريد ذلك يجب ان تبذل المزيد من
الجهود في مواجهه هذه المجموعات راينا ما
يحصل في جنين وما حصل في نابلس في الماضي
اراه الان في جنين وبالتالي السلطه
الفلسطينيه لا تتخذ تدابير حقيقيه من اجل
منع المجموعات الاصغر من ان تصبح اكبر
وتشكل مشكله لاسرائيل ولكن ايضا للسلطه
الفلسطينيه انيخين مراسله شؤون
الدبلوماسيه في هيئه البث الاسرائيليه من
القدس
ولتعميق النقاش ينضم الينا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين العام
للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه ومعنا من
واشنطن المستشار السابق لشؤون الامن
القوميه الامريكي وعضو مكتبي جو بايدن
عندما كان سيناتورا مرحبا بكما دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي سنبدا معك وتقييمك لما
يحدث
ولمسار هذه العمليه العسكريه التي ينفذها
جيش الاحتلال في جنين
انا جئت قبل قليل يعني قبل دقائق من جنين
ومن مخيم جنين حيث قضيت اليوم هناك
وما يقوله جيش الاحتلال ان عمليته لا تتم
في يوم واحد ليس الا اعترافا بالحقيقه
الجليه التي ترينها عندما تذهب الى جنين
وهو ان الاحتلال فشل فشلا ذريعا والعمليه
الاسرائيليه فشلت فشلا كاملا لان هدفها
المركزي والاساسي والاول كان ضرب
المقاومين ولم تستطع ان تصل لهؤلاء
المقاومين او معظمهم وبالتالي العمليه
فشلت وفقدت قوه
المفاجاه التي طمعوا ان يستغلونها ولكن
اضيفي الى ذلك ان فشلهم سيجلل الان بالعار
بعد ان قاموا بارتكاب جرائم حرب وحشيه هي
في الواقع ما يسمى ارهابا مثل اختراق
البيوت من جدار الى اخر مثل كما قال لنا
اهالي مخيم جنين عزل الاطفال في غرف
منفصله عن اهلهم
وترويعهم وترهيبهم للشهاده ضد اهلهم
واستخدام الكلاب لتخويف الاطفال المعزولين
عن اهلهم في غرف مغلقه هذا ما يقوم به
ضباط وجنود الاحتلال واضافوا الى ذلك
الجريمه الكبرى اليوم بالهجوم على
مستشفيين واطلاق الرصاص داخل المستشفيات
واصابه المواطنين داخل المستشفيات هذه
جريمه حرب مكتمله الاركان النتيجه الوحيده
لهذه العمليه هو الفشل الذريع والعار الذي
سيكلل كل من قاموا بالتخطيط لها وكما من
قاموا بتنفيذها في واقع الامر اسرائيل
فشلت وحتى لو استمرت هذه العمليه اطول او
تكررت انا برايي ستواجه نفس الفشل الجانب
الاخر للفشل للفشل وانا رايت اليوم في
شوارع الضفه الغربيه
انتفاضه شامله في كل القرى لا يوجد قريه
لا يوجد على مدخلها حواجز واشعال اطارات
وصدامات مع الجيش نفس الشيء في رام الله
في احياء القدس اشعلوا انتفاضه جديده
بسلوكهم الاجرامي وباعتدائهم الوحشي على
الشعب الفلسطيني
كما استمعت
القوات الاسرائيليه مقامت به عمليا في
جنين هو جرائم حرب وحشيه اختراق لبيوت
المدنيين عزل الاطفال اضيف بانها هجرت
الالاف هاجمت البنى التحتيه المدنيه
المستشفيات لماذا اختارت واشنطن ان تصطفى
الى جانب هكذا عمليه
انما تقوم به اداره بايدن واشنطن حاليا هو
محاوله القيام بالتقييم سريع حول بالضبط
ما الذي يحصل انا لا
افند ما قاله الضيف الاخر ولكن هناك فعلا
مشكله حقيقيه هنا بسبب ان
نتنياهو وحكومته
اقتحموا الضفه الغربيه كما قال المتحدث
السابق من اسرائيل الامر لا يتعلق بمشكله
اسرائيليه بل هي ايضا مشكله السلطه
الفلسطينيه
التي تزداد هنا
واعتقد من اخر الاحصائيات خلال الاسهم
السته الماضيه 140 فلسطينيه قتلوا
على يد الاسرائيليين وبالتالي هذا في وقت
ما لابد من التوصل من جانب السلطه
الفلسطينيه
والشركاء الاقليميين والولايات لابد عليهم
الجلوس سويه ليقولوا لماذا ان حماس موجوده
في جنين لماذا ان الجهات الاسلاميه
جلسوا سويا جلسوا سويا في العقبه وجلس
سويا في شرم الشيخ ولكن ماذا حصل انقلبت
بعد ساعات الحكومه الاسرائيليه على نتائج
هذه الاجتماعات التي اصلا كانت احرجت
السلطه الفلسطينيه بالذهاب اليها والان
ماذا حصل انتهى كل شيء حتى السلطه
الفلسطينيه تقول انه لا جد واصلا من
الذهاب الى هكذا اجتماعات لانه الالتزام
الالتزام من جانب الاحتلال
لدينا مثل هذه الاجتماع اجتماع ثم تتغير
الحكومه وتحاول تقربه الولايات المتحده
لم تتغير الحكومه سيد ديفيد لم تتغير
الحكومه نفس هذه الحكومه حكومه نتنياهو
نفسها شاركت في هذه الاجتماعات ولم تلتزم
والذي حصل هو انه
لم تلتزم لانه لم يكن هناك عليها ضغوط لكي
تلتزم وتحديدا من جانب الولايات المتحده
وانتهينا الى ما انتهينا اليه اليوم
انا ما اقوله انه هناك عمليه
انتقاليه حصل الماضيه ولا ضد الامور
تتصاعد والمناسبه هذا امر امر تاريخي
نتحدث عن هجمات حصلت في جنين
لم تحصل منذ عشرين سنه وهذا يعني تصعيد
تصعيد ان الرئيس بايدن ووزير الخارجيه
سيكون عليهما ان يبنوا على ما حصل ويحاسب
من قام بذلك هذا ما تقوم باداره بايدن
حاليا بدراسه الوضع علامه من خلال 24 ساعه
ثمانيه واربعين ساعه لا تزداد الامور سوءا
واعتقد هذا وما تقوم به واشنطن وتراقب
الامر عن كثب على الارجح تبعث باطراف
الدبلوماسيين الى الى
كيف نستطيع من حيث المبدا ان نهدا
[موسيقى]
نهدئ
الاعصاب في هذه الفتره وايقاف سفك الدماء
هل يمكن الرهان على اي موقف
خارجي موقف دولي بالنظر الى ما ترافق من
يعني المواقف التي ترافقت مع هذه العمليه
لا طبعا يعني نحن نشعر باستياء شديد من ما
قاله ممثل الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا
ودول غربيه اخرى عندما وصفوا قيام اسرائيل
بعمليات ارهابيه ضد شعب تحت الاحتلال
واستخدامها لكل منظومتها العسكريه بشان
حرب على شعب هي تحتله قالوا ان ذلك دفاع
عن النفس وكان الشعب الفلسطيني ليس من حقه
ان يدافع عن نفسه وكل ما قالوا ضيفك
الامريكي وقبله والتصريحات الاسرائيليه
يريد ان يتقاتل الفلسطينيون مع بعضهم
البعض يريد ان تكون بيننا حرب اهليه مقابل
ماذا
ولماذا ومن قال ان حركه حماس حركه معاديه
للشعب الفلسطيني كلنا اخوه وكلها حركات
فلسطينيه وطنيه تناضل معا وتعمل معا من
اجل فلسطين ماذا قدموا للسلطه الفلسطينيه
اصلا اهان السلطه الفلسطينيه كل يوم
يهنوها حرموها من اموالها
فرضوا عليها حصار اعلنوا يعني ما معنى
اتفاق واسلوه اذا كانت اسرائيل قد اعلنت
انها تنوي بناء مستوطنات في كل مكان وقال
نتنياهو ساقتلع فكره دوله فلسطينيه من
عقول الناس عن ماذا يجري الحديث اسرائيل
تريد ان تكون السلطه الفلسطينيه
وكيل امني لها وتريد ان يشتبك الفلسطينيون
مع بعضهم البعض وهذا ما يقوله هو
المتحدثون الامريكيون هذا لن يحدث ابدا
انا الذي رايت اليوم في جنين وافتخر واعتز
به وحده وطنيه رائعه بين المناضلين بين
المقاومين بين الاهالي بين الناس شعب
فلسطيني موحد بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه حصار
جنين محاصره مخيم جنين محاصر يعاني من
انقطاع الغذاء والكهرباء والماء كل مدن
وقرى الضفه الغربيه تندفع الان لتقديم
الاسناد والمساعده لمخيم جنين ولمدينه
جنين وعلى فكره الصراع لا يدور داخل
المخيم فقط مدينه جنين باكملها جبهه
والشباب يقاومون ويناضلون بكل ما يستطيعون
هذا شعب يناضل ضد الارهاب ضد الاحتلال
لماذا لا يتذكر الغرب ان هناك اسرائيل
التي تحتل الشعب الفلسطيني منذ 56 عاما في
الضفه
وطهرت تطهيرا عرقيا
ممارسه تطهير عرقي منذ 75 عاما سيدي انت
تقول لم تحصل مثل هكذا هجمات من مخيم جنين
منذ عشرين سنه ولكن ايضا لماذا لا تنظر
الى الجانب الاخر من القضيه حديث نتنياهو
عن اجتساس فكره دوله فلسطينيه هذا
الاستيطان الواسع والتمكين الواسع
للمستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه هذا هذه
الضغوط على السلطه الفلسطينيه كما يقول
ضيفه الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي ماذا تبقى
اذا لماذا
يعني يلقى باللائمه على طرف الفلسطيني ولا
ينظر الى الاحتلال وما فعل الاحتلال
هذا تماما وعود فقط ان اقول ان رئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو لم يواجه ازمه ما كان الا
ان يصعدها ودائما بشكل دائم يدفع الحدود
الى الى اقصى الحدود بحيث يمنع تاشيرات
العمل ويحدد ترخيصات لشراء المنازل او
بناء المنزل وهو يفقد ذلك ويصعد الامور
خلال اداراته المختلفه واداره بايدن لا
تؤيد ذلك ولا تدعم هذا
وتقول باننا لدينا حل الدولتين ولكن الامر
يتطلب العمل مع الاداره الموجوده في
السلطه حاليا فهو منتخب منتخب اسرائيل
ونحن نعمل معهم ذلك
نحن ايضا ندرك بان السلطه الفلسطينيه
تتحمل مسؤوليه منع المجموعات الارهابيه
جهاد الاسلامي وحماس وغيرهم
والمنظمات التي تدعمها ايران منعهم من
الاستخدام
ملاذ لها في هذه المناطق هذه المنظمات
والشعبياتها في الشارع الفلسطيني هي نتيجه
هذه النتيجه للاحتلال وهذا ليس سبب
موجوده فعلا في الضفه الغربيه هذا هو هذه
المشكله وان السلطه الفلسطينيه حسب رايي
كما يحق لها ان تبقى علق من وجهه نظر
الايات المتحده لكن المنظمات الارهابيه
الاخرى لا ترى ذلك وبالتالي اعتقد انما
تقوم باداره
او تحاول ان تقوم به فان كلما كنا هناك
مخيمات لاجئين موجوده فهم
يبدون
بتسجيع النقاشات بان هناك مجموعه ارهابيه
فيها ولابد ان ندخلها ونستخدم القوه
الجويه كما فعلوا في الساعات الماضيه
ويمكن ان تكون باستخدام عمليات اجراءات لم
تستخدم قبل 20 سنه وبالتالي التصعيد حاليا
لابد ان يواجه تخفيف التصعيد ولهذا ليس
فقط الولايات المتحده والمملكه المتحده بل
المجموعات الاقليميه الاخرى ينبغي ان
تشارك في ذلك
يعني يعني نفس يعني نفس المسار نفس المسار
الذي يحدث منذ تسعينات القرن الماضي دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي
رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه نتنياهو يقول
سنستمر طالما كان ذلك ضروريا للقضاء على
الارهاب وفق تعبيره لن نسمح لجنين بان
تكون ملجا للارهاب في كل الاحوال كما قال
في تصريحاته كيف يترجم ذلك ماذا يعني ذلك
بالنسبه لهذه الحكومه بالنسبه لاجنده
اليمين المتطرف في هذه الحكومه
ربما الى مشارف جنين اليوم ليعلن انتصار
وجاء ليجد فشلا وبالتالي تصريحاته بانه
سيكرر ما جره وتعترف بانه فشل في تحقيق
اهداف هذه العمليه طبعا هو سيستمر هو يشن
حرب على الشعب الفلسطيني ليس فقط بعمليات
الارهاب العسكريه التي يقوم بها بل ايضا
بالاستيطان الاجرامي الارهابي وباطلاق
العنان للمستوطنين الارهابيين الارهاب هو
ما تقوم به اسرائيل الفلسطينيون ليسوا
ارهابيين وانا اتساءل كيف تريد يعني
الولايات المتحده ان تصف فصائل فلسطينيه
بانها ارهابيه ومنظمه التحرير التي تريد
منها ان تحارب الفصائل التي تسميها
ارهابيه مصنفه في الولايات المتحده ايضا
كمنظمه ارهابيه في الكونجرس الامريكي باي
حق الشعب الذي تحت الاحتلال يصنف بانه
ارهابي والذين يقومون بقتله وقمعه
والتنكيل به وقتل اكثر من 100 الف شهيد
فلسطيني منذ عام 1948 هؤلاء ليس ارهابيين
الارهاب المنظم الحقيقي هو ما تقوم به
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده لو ارادت ان
تحترم القانون الدولي وتحترم نفس المعايير
التي تحاول ان تستعملها في اوكرانيا
وغيرها لفرضت عقوبات على اسرائيل لفرضت
عقوبات لردع اسرائيل عن الاستيطان ولكن ما
نراه نفاق دولي ولذلك انا اجيب على سؤالك
الاول نحن كشعب فلسطيني لم نعد ولا نريد
ان نتكل على اطراف خارجيه الشعب الفلسطيني
وهذا ما رايته في شباب جنين اليوم قرر
الاعتماد على النفس وتنظيم النفس وتوحيد
طاقاته وهذه الوحده الوطنيه الرائعه هي
التي ستصنع طريق نصر الشعب الفلسطيني ان
شاء الله وهم باحرار يسمون ارهابيين يسمون
ايش ما بدهم
الشعب الفلسطيني سينتصر اذكرهم اذكرهم بان
نيلسون مانديلا كان على قائمه الارهاب
ايضا تفضل دكتور مصطفى السيده يتحدث عن
انه ربما الاداره الامريكيه الان تذهب نحو
محاولات لخفض هذا التصعيد لتهدئه النفوس
طلب من الدول الاقليميه ربما التدخل ايضا
اين يمكن ان يذهب كل ذلك
اذا ارادوا ان يخفضوا التصعيد فليفرضوا
على نتنياهو وقف عملياته العسكريه
وليهددوا اسرائيل بانهم سيقطعوا عنها
المساعدات الماليه ان استمرت بالاستيطان
الولايات المتحده تقول ان الاستيطان يعطل
فكره قيام دوله مستقله وتقول انها تؤيد
فكره حل الدولتين فلتفرض على اسرائيل وقف
الاستيطان تستطيع ان تفعل ذلك لو ارادت
ولكن لا توجد اراده لا توجد حتى اراده
لفتح لمجرد فتح مكتب قنصليه امريكيه في
القدس كما وعدوا لا توجد اراده حتى لفتح
اعاده فتح مكتب منظمه التحرير في واشنطن
وهاي امور صغيره فهل سيستطيع ان يفرضوا
على اسرائيل وقف الاستيطان انا اشك في ذلك
ولذلك دعيني اقول ان ارادوا وقف التصعيد
عليهم اولا ان يوقفوا هذه العمليات
العسكريه الاجراميه التي تجري ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني وان يوقفوا ارهاب المستوطنين
الذي مس بالفلسطينيين وبعضهم حتى يحملوا
الجنسيه الامريكيه في قرى عديده عليهم ان
الاستعمار الاستيطاني وارهاب المستوطنين
اولا قبل ان يتحدثوا عن تهدئه او عن تحسين
الاوضاع ومره اخرى اذكر بما ذكرتيه حضرتك
الاجتماعات البائسه في شرم الشيخ والعقبه
تعهدت اسرائيل بان لا تقر مستوطنات جديده
فاقرت مئات الاف الوحدات الاستيطانيه
وعشرات المستوطنات تعهدوا بان لا يصعدوا
فشنوا هذه الهجمات اذا عن ماذا يتحدثون
نحن واعود بما يجري والشعب الفلسطيني واعي
وانا متاكد ان هذا الشعب سيواصل نضال لانه
يدرك انه محق جلدك مثل ظفرك كل هذه
العناصر التي تحدث عنها الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي هل تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار لدى
الاداره الامريكيه هل في ربما رؤيتها التي
لم نراها بعد يعني ولكن في الرؤيه لكيفيه
مقاربه هذه الازمه هل تؤخذ هذه الامور
بعين الاعتبار
لا استطيع ان استعرض كل نقطه بالنقاط
اليسارها زميلي قبل قليل هناك عده نعم
مقدار من النفاق في الموضوع صحيح
واتمنى ايضا راي غير صحيح بنقارنه الوضع
بما يحصل في اوكرانيا
وروسيا ولكن بشكل عام في كل مره
وهذا امر نحن نتحدث عنهم منذ اربعين عاما
حق الفلسطينيين السلطه الفلسطينيه بالوجود
وللشعب الفلسطيني بالوجود هو حق عميق
واساسي كما هو حق اسرائيل ان تعيش كدوله
وبالتالي اعتقد لدينا قوى مثل الايران
التي حتى لا تعترفوا بدوله اسرائيل
التي تمول وتشجع الكثير من الاعمال
الارهابيه فان يقول انه ليس هناك ارهابيين
في فلسطين هذا هذا غير صحيح
هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا
لمتابعتكم الان ننتقل الى نشره التاسعه
ويقدمها لكم الزميل حسن جمول الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]